previously on the walking dead what holy
[ __ ] what's your tip again yeah huh
everybody sit down now go get the meal
all right mind if I wash my hands first
mine don't eat dinner
don't eat that coming oh no huh I'll
break that diet Georgia dad you can't go
hi I feel like an [ __ ]
Oh what the [ __ ] do know how the gum
breath my name is Pippa let's keep
playing
walking dad this is so I don't like the
cat in I did Kenna get out I guess it
doesn't matter huh
so they're the one who put the beer oh
they're the one who put the beer Trappe
huh I told you there were something up
with this room
it's a goddamn human slaughterhouse well
you slaughter him is to Kenny what is he
doing taking a [ __ ] we're taking a [ __ ]
what's raining I hate you hook roll it
all bro are we gonna use that all right
cool
I guess this is where climate on came
through all right
well now I remember what we're doing
what up Kenny
what's the plan Ted Thomas is so caught
up in his own read that we could
probably sneak right up on it just stick
behind me in case anything goes down
when we get to the front grab is good
all right it's good let's do that you
ready I am ready man let's go yeah let's
go
stay close whoa oh I don't like this
Kenny Kenny I'm scared it's better if
one goes and then the other one God's
not good idea bro one should hide oh
poor guy poor God I'm playing favorites
alright then what are you doing outside
the bar whoa shut his gourd in the place
like you said
and here mama says we can't keep that
many folks alive and not expect from
ocean he know how the kid pray that
son-of-a-bitch was the grass ah when I
let one thing they can just walk right
out what's he do
I don't know I'm checking out his ass
it's making a beer truck see ya Kenny
give me a moment Jesus Christ
alright I'm talking to your crotch
apparently [ __ ]
well well take him out alright oh [ __ ]
I'm taking it out I shot me scared man I
wasn't ready for that I don't look I'm
in I got I wasn't ready for it all right
okay I'm clicking oh [ __ ] that's loud
bro oh it's fighting I'm meathook Mitch
oh oh ah
bro oh [ __ ] get it do something thank
you're kidding whoa nuts go and get it
oh that's Oh ahh bra sister say this
tonight I'm not I mean say men where's
my family [ __ ] you can't have them
we need the vet Oh can't lie come on
just go I won't be far behind we need to
what am i doing what am i doing I might
make it a decision here ha ha ha oh it's
go time [ __ ] you see you understand now
don't you you can have
but that means how the world works now
get part of yourself so others can live
ah get about it what what happened
catabolism is not the answer
aren't the walkers eating enough of us
yeah gotta keep him aiive
if you kill me the meat gets tainted you
can't eat it you're already tainted yeah
kill me just like he didn't kill Joleen
you don't have what it takes
hey [ __ ] coward aah
enough telling already man on how the
world works now not you now and man me
kill you why is he holding doing Kenny
murder my dad but you leave this side
well Clemmy we'll remember that's all I
care about
Oh God
don't hurt him that's culture oh [ __ ]
what's up Clemmy what are you looking at
me like that
Lily please keep her safe what what in
the heavens don't I get the feeling
we're gonna get separated with
Clementine and I don't like it what I
don't like dad I don't like his breasts
Jimmy there's another two of them left
where's Carly anyway he's got to do some
good I mean I saved her ass go shed
either the walkers I think it's the
walkers yeah the fens are not on right
now whoa good yeah finally Carly
nice going bran behind you got it Oh Shh
nevermind okay we heard screams as we
were coming up to the house
why are you we need your help need your
help
yeah you guys didn't come back I figured
something was up
what can we do there he's dead they
chopped off marks legs and tried to feed
them to us daddy fell right what else
okay they've still got ducking gotcha in
the house and I don't know where the
[ __ ] it E is all right we're coming in
to help the main gate is too dangerous
go around the fence and see if there's a
back way in I'll keep looking for Kenny
do you have a weapon I don't leave home
without it
all right Italy be careful I don't trust
Ben yet I don't my Ben man can't trust
anyone in this game except climie are
they raping I don't think I have to
sneak when there's a [ __ ] storm
outside I'm crazy boy oh all right Kelly
all right hey hey whatever you what's
going on out there
hi Jenny uh I left Danny Barney the bar
he got what he deserved
no I need me to do that I was gonna go
sneaky money oh [ __ ] leave it back don't
come in here
oh you gotta free time mrs. Blaine cuz
it's disgusting
all right what do I do
back off [ __ ] wait I'll announce your
blank killed her come on get out you
know you don't want to do this
alright girl we can reason about this
just put the gun down
you're both fat Hey alright alright
alright
point the gun at I'm Brenda but you're
going down bad chomp it's a shot [ __ ]
Joey just chug man god damn it I mean
okay okay okay I get it stop shouting me
for [ __ ] sake
Jesus guys what's wrong with your mom n
okay keep going backward aren't gonna do
anything
um Madiga brand printer please listen to
him
go back I'll do it
God how's that you got there's nothing
behind you anything like that all right
keep going you stupid son of a [ __ ] I
don't wanna kill you me well then don't
do it
there's that simple
please don't make this any worse don't
make it any worse
just stop keep going back keep going
back good now I know oh no no no don't
you [ __ ] hurting oh my god
all right you gotta save Ken Avenue Cal
hey Cal hey Cal hey Cal oh no now who
the [ __ ] do you people think you know
look nice shut up shut the [ __ ] up girl
you think I'm playin here boy
oh we got our plan we came to you
Facebook that's right Oh Leona bear Cuyo
I'm gonna cube the [ __ ] out of you
IQ that like a boss Oh in your face
[ __ ]
oh that's right oh that's right oh ow ow
holy [ __ ] the generator it doesn't work
you stupid [ __ ] oh it does he fixed
it
oh no Carly shut up please
touch it [ __ ] take a little high oh
no no wait oh no oh I'm [ __ ] help
Lilly oh you son of a [ __ ] Lily he's
son of a [ __ ] I remember that Carly
Carly Carly
[ __ ] you Lilly I'm gonna kill her for
this oh it's bitch-slapping time this
part is for oh [ __ ] never mind oh
alright now we're back okay can I hit
him I'm a terrible fighter
that's right electrified [ __ ]
Oh Kenny don't tell me is that all you
got Lee you were [ __ ]
it's over mother oh holy [ __ ] [ __ ] you
no [ __ ] you Judith Danny mama get out
here dude oh [ __ ] that it's all that
it's over
just walk away get out of here don't you
dare walk away from me leave Iran
I just dead [ __ ] get back here
and finish this Lee
oh no we don't stay right there I got a
choice shoot him Oh Kenny's alive or
walk away
walk away Lee walk away get back here
and fight me like a man Lee no se
stop working
that was fast
[ __ ] off let's go
it's coming there
okay that was awesome about it's
freaking epic
at the end of episode I think so
goddamn goddamn I love this game
Kerry got shot you just bent back up
Clemmy Clemmy are you angry at me
Clemmy I did I'd save that man you know
that right
Haley I'd say I'm sorry for leaving the
motel unattended but you know I'm glad
you showed up when you did
if you hadn't taken that saturd Andy we
might not have gotten out of there were
they really killing people for food yep
climate on homeless Asia and Clementine
almost eight song but that's doctor yeah
can't leave her alone Carly this [ __ ]
world now tied and just unspeakable [ __ ]
at every turn how'd she manage to grab
this while she was in the house she said
it was with your stuff oh yeah I found
it while I was looking for the people
who shot MA
oh yeah I want it she has the battery
sometimes it helps to have something you
can document your thoughts on ah how are
you doing I'll be fine
I'm just not as young as I used to be
and you got friggin shot writing they
killed ah go on ahead and give me in Lee
a second alright it's the end Brea's
what's up Kenny there's gonna be fallout
yeah for killing Lily's dad
yeah I would imagine so what do you
think I'm with you man zucchini will do
what has to be done you're damn right
listen that RV back at the Motor Inn is
just about ready I've changed my mind
I want you to come with us when we leave
all righty then I'll ask lemon hell yeah
we're a team man me and you by taking
out Larry before he turned you saved all
of us in that meat locker and that saved
my family too yeah I'd say you earned it
all right then you kinda killed Larry I
didn't really do a clipping to stay
close we are those bad people dead we
didn't kill I didn't kill them so I
don't know they might have been able to
get away from the walkers but I'm sure
they won't be coming after us that's
good yep no way back honey what's that
noise I don't know it's called thunder
you [ __ ]
sounds like a car Oh God
not more strangers good strangers never
good news in this game
what is that
Oh holy [ __ ]
maybe more of the bandits all right this
is where's the rain don't shoot we're
here to help well approach the car
slowly
all right I'm dirty breasts why do I
have a camera right now I don't think
they would shoot that doesn't make sense
what is that Leigh you're totally
covering bush doesn't have any gas oh
crap baby you gotta see this
that's a lot of shitload of food and
supplies back here
oh that's our food and supplies now yes
sir we found ood could save all of us
not all of us Lily
you gotta let it go man you didn't save
me back there let's say we leave Douglas
and Lily right here if they come back
then we're just monsters who came out of
the woods and ruined their lives this
stuff isn't ours dad whose car is it
don't worry about that duck it's ours
now it's abandoned ducky don't worry
what if it's not get damaged climates
not abandoned what if it is someone's
don't make it difficult for me kaimei
all right come on rest
Clemmy Clemmy don't put pressure on me
fine god damn you're right you're right
we shouldn't take this Michelle yeah
did you get some meal back there the
rest of us missed out on we have to take
this stuff
we've done enough damage already damaged
already you mean by that come on Kenny
between this and the meat locker
you know what it means fine suit
yourself now the rest of us are taking
this stuff
no no hey oh okay
okay what we got in here look there's
more food in that box
they have antibiotics what else do they
have see if there's any water here look
at that [ __ ] face got it yeah I got
it all right Lee there's a hoodie in
here could probably fit Clementine are
you trying to tease me or something
you look good in that hoodie climby
she's good
Thanks whatever man it's gonna get cold
out eventually
hey there were some batteries in one of
those boxes I thought they might work in
your camcorder here
you can have some too are your walkie
talkie battery son
think you can handle those you're not
gonna let me live that down are you
ha ha ha stupid girl doesn't know how to
work battery but Lee you're gonna want
to see this
what is it should what is that what it
what was it I don't know about it read
oh they were watching what's going on
here
oh she's obsessed with Clementine J bar
land on all y'all [ __ ] sickos from
the save what they call y'all bandits
but you're [ __ ] what Oh darlin baby
look at you
oh no you oh you need a mom a sweetheart
we won't let that bandits get you where
we okay where's your oh it was this
moment how can they hear me from home
what did you lose it thinking you're
safe though sitting there I cannot
things are the way they used to be the
dead don't kill their own it's living
you gotta be afraid of the people I used
to call friends people
don't worry little girl and it's got
their eye on that Darien as long as they
keep getting food from them you be safe
I promise
but she died anyway so that doesn't
really change anything well next time on
Walking Dead all right here we go
bread-making his done pal ain't nothing
left we got to get the hell out of here
Lee I need you to back me up on this
it's this all you got I told you this
town is tapped do you have any idea what
we had to do to get all that huh
we need to leave duck was asking about
the farm last night not much crazy it's
starting to add up
I need to get to the coast get him out
of all this madness well he's not doing
so good huh what we killed her dad we
did kill her dad ha ha ha ha maybe
people out there got things lined up
they're better than us at least how we
going under train right [ __ ] figured out
do people get mad when they're scared
sometimes yeah they do this is crazy I'm
the one keeping this group going we can
sort this all out all right we can sort
this out I'll tell you what we need to
sort out we can't let one person [ __ ]
this up for everyone else
oh if it's Audrey I'm glad I don't have
to wait for it I'm so glad I don't have
to wait for it
all right let's see it I chop David's I
got most people did it apparently all
you could do is either chop it off or
just leave and be 87 percent shot Joleen
you had oh Danny shot her so 87 percent
didn't you all right god damn it I felt
like good for not shooting her all right
how many helped kill Larry well I guess
people didn't like Larry
so I guess oh I'm very fighting to kill
a zombie look at me like that and got
dead alright killed both alright so most
people didn't kill him god damn it I
thought I was being all like justified
and [ __ ]
I suck apparently all right so 44% it's
so it was 5050 with Luke tonight what I
got a trust with Clemmy once
let's this out it she's lady all right
this time I'm gonna wait for the credits
to finish idli but you don't have to
watch it anyway I compared it to be
enjoyed
again I'm really happy you bros are so
excited about this series I am freakin
love this game as an epic episode and
yeah they all surprise yeah hey can I
meet him
yeah is he here yeah I'm gonna go get
her all right doll the way safale is
awesome Paul faces
mystify oh okay I see you